violence and bullying both top of mind
within ccsd ahead of a special
discussion with the board of trustees
one family is speaking out about their
experience a second grader saying that
her bully went to great lengths to hurt
her victoria saha digs into why this
family feels the school failed them
brian and denise were talking about an
eight-year-old hurting another
eight-year-old throughout the school
year there were mean comments from this
classmate but then yesterday it went too
far according to the victim's mom and
her daughter was stabbed by this student
with a pencil
i was just dancing
showing them how to dance it was a
typical day for eight-year-old aliyah at
mark fine elementary when she says her
bully charged at her he was walking to
me and then he went like this and then
he walked away leah was stabbed in her
thigh by this student with a pencil the
lead still visible the next day i
screamed leah says she has been the
target of this student before one day he
said that i'm ugly mom ashley braverman
says she has made numerous complaints to
the school for the continuous bullying
but nothing was ever done but this
stabbing incident was the last straw all
the breath was taken out of me and my
body began to shake in all those alleged
bullying incidents leah's teacher never
informed her mom it was leah who had to
tell her if leah wasn't the type of kid
to tell me i would have never known that
he was hurting her and then would she
tell me if she was having thoughts to
hurt herself then which is why she feels
the school teacher and ccsd failed her
daughter they failed to protect her
they failed her safety
her rights she was told all they could
do is move the students to another class
i think they could just suspend him
not bullying me
to not bully me anymore
i reached out to the school district
about this situation they said they
could not discuss individual cases but
say in a general in general students can
face administrative disciplinary action
at school or be referred to law
enforcement for possible criminal
prosecution and i also reached out to
the school district police they say they
couldn't take action because this child
is under 10 years old brian